and that opportunity a man impeached and
emboldened Jeff will be joining the
Republican Party and I really to me it's
a very exciting announcement embracing a
very rare breed a Democrats willing to
switch sides it doesn't feel like
impeachment and you know what it's a
phony deal and they cheapen the word in
Pietra it's an ugly word but they
cheapen the word impeachment that should
never again happen to another president
and I think you'll see some very
interesting things happen over the
coming few days and weeks depending on
where you sit in the smoke and chaos of
the Capitol this impeachment was either
a coup or a constitutional duty but it's
not over the Republicans are enraged
frustrated by the Democrats who say
they're now not ready to hand over the
articles of impeachment needed to start
the Senate trial mr. president looks
like the prosecutors are getting cold
feet in front of the entire country and
second-guessing whether they even want
to go to trial they said impeachment was
so urgent that it could not even wait
for due process but now they're content
to sit on their hands this is really
comical but the other side say they're
trying to stop a kangaroo court
leader McConnell is plotting the most
rushed least thorough and most unfair
impeachment trial in modern history his
plan to prevent house managers from
calling witnesses to prove their case is
a dramatic break from precedent it is an
era of toxic politics a Washington
whirlwind that doesn't seem to reflect
what voters most care about Democrats
say they had to move to protect
America's democracy the president claims
they're waging war in it but away from
this small corner of America is far from
top of most people's priority lists and
there's little patience for a protracted
battle
Donald Trump wants vindication but his
supporters have given him validation
already they believe he's the victim of
a partisan persecution the impeachment
was a moment in history front page news
across the world but Donald Trump has
rewritten the presidency and the longer
it takes Republicans in the Senate to
acquit him the more he'll try to
capitalize on it cordelia Lynch Sky News
Washington